- [Mark] Alright. What are your names?
- Shane Stiffler and
- I'm Kelly Stiffler
- [Mark] Son and mom, right?
- Yep.
- [Mark] And you guys are from where?
- [Kelly] Michigan.
- [Mark] Detroit?
- [Shane] We're outside
Detroit, in Munro, Michigan.
- [Mark] And you're out here in skid road.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mark] How long have you been here?
- [Shane] 30 days.
- No. a little bit longer. About 5 weeks.
- About 5 weeks, 6 weeks.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What do you
think of the neighborhood?
- It's crazy.
- [Mark] Yes, it is.
- It's pretty crazy.
- Sirens go past.
- Yeah. Like every five minutes.
- Yeah.
- I've just never seen stuff like this.
I mean we have like, but
this is like out there.
- [Mark] Anything in
Detroit this hard core?
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, yeah. Worse. I'd say,
just not as fast paced.
You know what I mean?
It's slower, it's more.
- Yeah. Like slow moving,
slow motion. Like, yeah.
- More discreet.
- [Mark] Is there something
going on here like all day?
- Yeah. It's busy here. It's fast.
- [Mark] So tell me about your past.
When you were a kid, Shane,
you grew up with mom,
mom and dad or just mom?
- My, my mom and my dad were together
until I was what, we were about four.
I was about four.
And then my ma got addicted
to crack cocaine, and left.
And then,
- [Mark] Your mom did?
- Yup. And then my, all
my brothers and sisters
went to foster homes.
I went to my grandma's.
And my other brother went
to a friend of the family.
And then my dad went to prison.
And I stayed with my grandma
for, till I was about 12.
And then my dad ended up getting me
and my younger brother, Kevin back.
Out of all of us, there's nine of us
me and my brother, Kevin,
and my brother, Jason,
he was, he wasn't my dad's,
but my dad raised him
as his own until he was about 13
until he was too, you
know, too hard to handle.
And a friend of the family adopted him.
And we, me and my brother
stayed with my dad
for the majority of the time.
But he was a real bad
alcoholic and, you know
beat the fucking shit out of us every day.
And we were you know, we
were allowed to do whatever
there was no rules, there was no,
you know, we, we raised ourselves.
You know what I mean?
I raised my little brother.
So anything that I was getting
into at 12, 11, 13, and 14
he was doing at seven and eight.
So he got exposed to some
shit way earlier than I did.
You know.
- [Mark] Where's he today?
- He's in Michigan. He's done three counts
or he's done three sets in prison already.
He's 20, what's he 27 or 28 now?
He was in prison, 27,
shit he was in prison
by the time when he was 17.
He's done three sets already.
He's done probably fuck,
almost half of his life
in juvie and in and out of prison.
And yeah. He's like 5'2", so
he's got little man syndrome.
And he'd just, he'd fight
the biggest dude in the world, man.
You know, he just, he was, he's hard core.
And you know, I'm
probably the one to blame
you know what I mean, for
exposing them to everything?
You know what I mean?
I just, if I did it, he was
right there with me, you know?
- [Mark] So mom, I'm
sorry what was your name?
- My name's Kelly.
- [Mark] So Kelly, where
were you at this time?
- I was smoking crack.
- [Mark] And you were on the street?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you left the kids.
- With their dad.
- [Mark] With dad and you were?
- Yep. And then I went to prison.
So I went to prison three times.
So I was, after the first time after,
when I really got addicted, when I first
when I got addicted the
first time I smoked it.
But my brother's the one
that got me started on it.
And then, I used to be
totally against drugs
and then I see my brothers and my,
all my brothers are doing it.
They're having cocaine parties
and just people everywhere.
And you know what I mean?
And just doing lines and doing lines.
And I was pregnant and I was
like, I don't want to do it.
And they just kept, do a
line, do a line, just do it.
And I'm like, fuck it. I'll do it.
And then my brother, Billy came over
and cooked, we were doing lines and he
I went to the bathroom and he said
and when I come out and then my coke,
all my coke is in the microwave.
He's cooking it up,
making crack out of it.
And then I'm like, what
the fuck are you doing?
And then he's like, just
wait until it's done.
You're going to love it.
And then he put some in a pipe
and then he handed it to me
and I blow out a cloud and I
just throw the pipe at him.
I'm like, I don't fucking feel nothing.
And he's like, let me do it for you.
And then he showed me how
to, you know what I mean?
Burn the pipe and hit it
and that's all it took.
- [Mark] Have you been
addicted ever since?
- Yeah.
I've been clean from that for four years.
It'll be four years in June.
- [Mark] So you're clean right now?
- From crack, yes.
- [Mark] What are you using now?
- Meth.
- [Mark] Is that the case
for you as well, Shane?
- I don't, I do black.
- [Mark] Oh, you do heroin?
- Yeah. Heroin.
That's always been like my drug of choice.
I go on and off.
Like I, you know, like I got like,
Oh, I know it's fucking crazy.
I can achieve so much in
life and I can do so good.
And I can,
You know, I've had five fortunes
and squandered them all.
You know what I mean?
Like I get to where I have a
house and cars and money and
you know, and then I just get bored.
You know what I mean?
I like, I fucking, that's when I'm clean.
I, you know, I put my, you know,
I put my feet to the ground
and I buckle in, I get
a job and then I start
saving everything and then
I start doing really good
and I get a house and I get
cars and I get motorcycles
and I get money in the bank.
And then I get complacent.
I get tired of just being
a slave and working.
- He's like two totally different people.
- Yeah. You know, I like, I
just, I start to get bored.
So then I'm like, you know, I'm
living paycheck to paycheck.
I have all these nice things
and everything's going really good.
But in the back of my
mind, I'm just bored.
You know what I mean?
I'm just like fuck, what
am I doing this for?
You know what I mean?
I'm working every day just
to, you know, come home,
eat, sleep, shit, go to
work, eat, sleep, shit, go.
You know what I mean?
It's just it's routine
and routine and routine
and it gets, it gets old.
So I fucking, throw a fork in the cog
and mess it all up.
I'll start selling drugs again.
And going back to that. You know?
- When he sells drugs, he sells them.
He don't, he ain't playing.
- No, I, you know, like
I go to the, you know
I just take it to the extreme.
I go to the fullest, I make
thousands of dollars and
you know, but then that
comes with the tech, you know
I always got a gun on me
and I'm always, I go crazy.
You know what I mean?
I start, I've always sold
cocaine and, you know
I'd stay up for days on
end snorting lines of coke.
And fucking go crazy doing, you know,
like shooting at people
and sticking guns in people's faces
and running from the cops.
And then I'd end up in
jail and then fucking
you know and I'd be, I'd finally get out
or I'd lose my apartment and then
I'd be living in one of my cars
and I'd sell this car and get raided.
And then I'd be right
back on the street again
and sell everything.
And then I'm like fuck.
I, you know, I'm, start
shooting heroin again.
You know what I mean?
Then none at all.
So then I'd, you know and I'd
be homeless on the street.
And then I'd do heroin for
about six, seven, eight months.
And then until I got to
where I was bored with that
and sick of that, and then I'd clean up
and fucking go get a
job, start saving money
and go get an apartment
and started doing that all.
- He didn't even give it a
chance this last time though,
he got out and he swore up and down
he wasn't going to do it.
And as soon as he got
out, not even like why.
He tried to hide it from
me, but I knew, you know.
- Well I stayed clean for about...
- Maybe a week.
- No, a month.
- [Mark] Kelly, tell me
about your childhood.
- My childhood?
- [Mark] What was your childhood like?
- Well, when my childhood,
my mom died when I was seven.
And I had nine older brothers
and sisters, I'm the baby.
And then when my mom died,
I was seven years old.
And then my family, my
brothers and sisters
were like pushing me away
and they didn't want me hanging out,
with the little baby sister, you know.
So I raised myself since I was seven.
My dad turned into an alcoholic
and he couldn't deal with my mom's death.
And then he tried to
kill himself a few times
and I would come home from school and
and find him country
music would be blaring
and he would be passed out on the floor
and all his pills would
be laying next to him.
And his friends would all be there.
And it was just a bad scene.
My mom's pictures laying all
around the house, you know?
And then I would just run.
I'd come in and I never wanted to go home.
I always asked my friends
if I could come home
with them after school.
And then, you know, because
I never wanted to go home.
Because I knew what I was coming home to.
And then when I was probably about 14
that's when I started being bad
and rebelling and you know what I mean?
Just I was, they called
me Roadrunner and then
but nobody in my family really liked me.
They might have cared about me.
But they just like, you know...
- You're the outcast.
- Kelly, yeah. I'm the
black sheep of the family.
And I had nine kids and
not custody of any of them.
And then the crack came
and the crack really
took it away from me and,
you know, and I was just out there.
And I mean bad,
prostituting and everything.
And I never said it in
front of my son before.
It's embarrassing.
- Oh, I knew.
- I'm sure he knows.
And, but I was bad.
I like really bad. I was
weighed like 98 pounds and
I just, I wouldn't go home,
it would be like Christmas
and like the holidays and
Easter and I would just,
I remember just sitting, like
sitting in a park by myself
and just crying and you
know wishing I was at home.
You know, with my family.
- [Mark] Do you see a connection
between your childhood
and the way you ended up and
then your children's lives?
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] It's almost like it continues.
- Yeah. And I hate it,
you know what I mean?
When we get high together and you know,
when people say like,
Oh, you're the best mom.
And I'm like, I'm really not, you know.
I suck at being a mom but they're like,
well, my mom's a bitch
and she would never,
you know, let me get high, well
we never got high together.
But I mean, it's not a good thing,
I mean he's going to do what he wants,
but at least I get to
be with him, you know?
And we been together every day
for like the past, what? Three, two years.
- [Mark] You guys live in a tent now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Around the corner?
- We had to move today. So
we're down this way now.
- I moved to Oregon and I
had met a girl in Detroit.
I was homeless. I had just got
out of jail and was homeless
and met a girl online and you know
told her everything about my life.
And she was like, well shit,
you can come stay with me.
I just moved in with her and her friend.
And we started, you know, going to Detroit
and buying coke and going back to Toledo
and selling it and started getting,
started smoking crack and stuff together.
And I was clean off heroin,
I wasn't doing heroin.
And then like after about six months of us
staying at her friend's
house, she kept her job
and she comes from a
really wealthy family.
And I didn't know this at the time,
she always kept that a secret.
And she always kept a job and she,
work was everything to her,
but when she'd come home,
we'd be getting high and everything.
And then her friend
found out that we were,
she found a crack pipe in the room
and found out we were smoking.
And we just basically told her everything
you know what I mean?
I had warrants out of Michigan
and warrants out of Ohio.
So I was running from the law.
And I'm like, fuck it, dude.
Let's just pack the car
with everything we got.
And we found, we went
to the bar that night
and we found 50 Oxy,
30, Oxy or no perc 30s,
somebody had dropped a bag.
I think there was 51 of them in there.
Perc 30s and in Detroit
they go for $30 a pop.
So I sold all of them for 1,700.
So we had some money,
you know what I mean?
So I'm like, this is perfect.
You know what I mean?
We can pack the car and
we can get on the road.
And we were just, we
called our friends in Texas
And we, we were planning on going to Texas
and living with our friends in Texas.
And we'd get out to Texas
and there's nowhere for us to stay.
We're living in a tent.
- So they came to me.
- It was hot as hell.
She had some warrants in Michigan.
So she went to Florida and
was staying with her niece.
And then met this guy online
and moved in with him.
So we didn't have nowhere
to go, me and my girl.
So we're like, screw it, let's go,
you know, stay with my mom.
So we could go there and stay in Florida.
So we drove to Florida.
- And this house was trashed.
- And this house was so
disgusting and nasty.
- I had to make him redo the
whole house and everything.
- It stunk so bad when I walked in.
- He left before all that happened.
- He had seven pit bulls
and half of them had mange.
So bad that they didn't
have a hair on their body.
As soon as I walked in
the house, I'm like...
- Where's the back door?
- That's what I said.
- I walked straight outside and was like,
mom, I'm sorry I can't do it, dude.
I can't take that smell.
I couldn't even eat food in
the house. It was so bad.
We might be on the street,
but it's still clean.
It's still gotta be clean,
you know what I mean?
It's still got to have that.
- [Mark] So if you stand
back and look at your lives
and your lifestyle, I
mean, what do you think?
What do you see?
- It's a wonder we're still alive.
- It's a tornado man.
- It's a wonder I'm
still alive. I know that.
- Me too.
- Him too.
- [Mark] I mean, what
do you think would have
taken you guys on a different direction?
- Not doing drugs.
- Not doing drugs. Drugs,
drugs take everything away.
- I used to say having a mom or, you know
having a mom and dad, that's
got a lot to do with it too.
- [Mark] That's I think one
step deeper than the drugs.
- Oh, definitely. Definitely.
Because my mom was, you know...
- [Mark] Because I mean the drugs
are just a symptom of the...
- Of the pain, you got pain and you got...
- It takes it away.
- And the drugs take the pain away.
- Yep.
- You know what I'm saying?
That's why I would always,
I got eight kids myself,
you know what I'm saying.
I have eight kids and a granddaughter.
- I have 9.
- I have a 19 year old daughter.
- [Mark] All by the same woman?
- No, I've got five baby
mommas. Five baby mommas.
And I, you know, I had my first wife,
we were together, we had identical twins.
Then we had two more daughters
and life was amazing.
You know, we had a nice
house, we had cars,
I was working, I was
working doing construction.
I'm a journeyman carpenter.
You know, I was making $26 an hour,
Coming home, you know with the family.
Had my boys, had my girls
and everything was cool.
And I've been doing tattoos
since I was like 13.
It's just like a little
side hustle, you know.
I'm really good at them though, you know
I've been a professional tattoo artist
for like 10 years now. But I set up a shop
in my apartment and my
wife had just had the twins
and she ran out of her Percosets.
And she had a C-section on her stomach
and she ran out of her pills
and she started laying on the couch
and she was crying and she's hurting.
And she's like, ah, you know,
I'm in pain, I'm in pain.
What can you do for me?
I'm like, there's babe there's
ain't nothing I can do.
And I just happened to be
tattooing this Mexican kid.
And he's like, bro, I got some heroin.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm like, well, my
brother does heroin.
He says it's like opiates.
It's the same thing as pills.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like, well, babe, you
could do a line of this,
you know this heroin.
And you know, if it will
make you feel better.
So she does a line and I'm like, fuck it,
I'll do a line too.
So he ends up living across the hall.
You know what I'm saying?
So now there's a fucking drug
dealer that lives across.
The first time I ever did heroin.
And 20 minutes later,
she's up, she's cleaning.
She feels good. She's
like, dude, I feel amazing.
And I finish this tattoo and
the tattoo just comes out,
flawlessly. You know what I mean?
Because I could slow down and I could.
So I started using that as an excuse to,
I'm about to go do a
tattoo, I'm going to go get
a 20 sack of dope. You know what I mean?
So I could do this tattoo really good.
I could calm down, slow down.
- You started shooting right away?
- And then yeah, Jason, my older brother,
was a heroin addict and he always told me,
Yeah, if you fucking snort
it, you're wasting it.
So I just immediately was like,
I'm going to get a bag of rigs.
I started shooting dope.
Within six months I had lost my job.
I had lost the apartment, me and the twins
and the two girls and my girl
were living out of my car.
And then we're living, I'm doing tattoos
in Detroit at the dope man's house.
And we're living with four
kids at the dope man's house.
And paying for rent.
And our drug habit with me doing tattoos.
So I'm staying up all day, all night
tattooing everybody that
comes over to the house
I'm trading dope for work or whatever.
And eventually my sister
called me and was like,
Hey dude you guys are in a bad place.
Let me take the kids.
You know what I'm saying?
So you guys ain't got the
kids in this, you know
in this environment and everything.
And I'm like, all right.
So I give her the kids and then...
- Never got them back.
- Well like we, I fought,
you know, I ended up,
like we ended up moving
into this other house.
This old lady was, she was real.
She like seventy years
old, but her daughter,
we had went over there to do a tattoo.
Because we needed to spot the tattoo.
And her daughter was
shooting her up with heroin
and getting her to spend
all of her SSI money
on crack and just like extorting her mind.
You know what I mean?
And obviously it's like,
man, this is fucked up.
You know what I mean?
So I'm like, I take her to the room
and I'm like, yo, your
daughters doing you dirty dude,
like, you know, robbing
her, taking all her money,
taking her gold rings and shit.
And I'm like, you need to
kick that girl out, dude,
and let me and my girl come and move in.
Dude we'll take care of you.
You know what I mean?
Like I might be a drug
addict and a piece of shit
but I'm still, I still respect my elders.
You know what I mean?
I'm like this, you know,
I'm in. So I clean the house
and I'm paying her bills with her card.
Making sure, you know what I'm saying?
She has a place to stay, you know?
And she passed away while
we was living there.
I came home one day...
- She OD'ed?
- No she, well, I mean, I
don't know. I don't know.
I just, we came home
and she was on the floor
and she had passed away.
And you know, she was dead.
And I broke in, broke in the
house and called an ambulance.
And we stayed in the
house for about a month
after she had passed away.
Until the landlord came and
kicked us out and everything.
And then I was just, I
was so fed up with it.
I'm like, I'm getting
clean, dude. I'm done.
I laid in bed for 17 days.
The worst detox I ever
went through in my life.
17 days of kicking heroin
and it was fentanyl
it was, it was Detroit dope.
So it was the best dope
in the world. You know.
One pack could kill somebody.
I was doing 25 packs in a shot.
- What?
- Yeah. I would put, I would
go buy two bundles, dude.
It was 200, 200 bucks I'd
get, I'd get 26 packs.
I'd put them all on the spoon.
- Wow.
And I take somebody to Detroit with me
and they'd get one
pack. One pack $10 pack.
And do one and be folded.
Me in the backseat.
Couple of my friends
had died off one pack...
- How are you still alive?
- And I'd put 24 of them in the spoon dude
and go to load it up and
my friends would be like,
what are you doing, dude?
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Like, you're going
to kill yourself, bro.
And I'm like, you sound crazy dude.
And boom and I'd do it. And
it wouldn't even get me high.
- [Mark] And you got clean from that?
- Believe me, I got clean from that, yeah.
I walked away from, straight from doing
two bundles in a shot.
- [Mark] On your own.
- On my own, yeah.
Cold Turkey, seven, the worst
detox I ever did in my life.
- [Mark] That's impressive.
And I laid in bed and I
did it on top of my girl
having the same habit with me.
And I was strong enough
to fight for both of us.
You know what I mean?
She laid there right there next to me.
- [Mark] She was using?
- She was using just as much as I was.
- [Mark] And you stopped?
- And I quit and I said,
you're quitting too.
- [Mark] So she quit as well?
- I mean she quit, she
had no other choice.
So, and then what was crazy is my dope,
my dope dealer lived right above us.
So at any point in time, I
mean, it was to the point
to where we were puking up blood and just
I mean, it was, it was, we
didn't sleep for 17 days.
That's why I say it was the 17 day detox
because the 17th day I finally
got a couple hours of sleep.
So we were just fighting
and fighting and I was just,
I took heroin and I just
looked at it like, I hate you.
You know what I mean?
And I, and I would just get,
any time I got an urge or any
you know what I mean?
The urge never left, but I would just,
- Fired.
- I would just get pissed and be like
fuck, fuck you heroin, I'm done, I'm done.
And I'd cry. And I'd
like, maybe praying to God
and doing whatever we could,
just to fight it another day.
And we finally did it.
And we, she moved to Toledo.
And I got a job in Detroit on Nine Mile,
doing hardwood floors
with my buddy Spencer.
And we stayed clean for, me and him,
he was kicking, he kicked heroin too.
We had met in jail and then
I had ran back into him,
we got a job and we were going to concerts
and we were going to
festivals and you know
we were messing around and then...
- He died.
- He passed away. He
ended up going to a rehab.
He wanted that though. The
whole time we were in Detroit
we were doing ecstasy and
cocaine and stuff like that.
But we stayed away from heroin.
He wanted to go back to
this rehab that he was in,
in Toledo. Because he was
the manager of the house
and he, you know, he liked
it. He said he really,
he liked that atmosphere
and helping people.
And he said, dude, I
think I'm going to go back
to this rehab in Toledo,
you should come with me.
And I'm like, I'll go to Toledo with you.
And I got hooked back up with my ex wife.
And when I got back to Toledo, I was clean
for the whole eight nine months
that we were working in Detroit.
And he went to the halfway house.
I got hooked up with my ex, with my wife
that I had the twins with,
and she was strung out.
And I immediately started using again.
You know what I mean?
We got into his family house program
to try to get our kids back.
And I ended up going to
jail for a stolen truck
that we were riding around in.
And I had hit a lick at
Walmart and was stealing.
I was boosting everyday.
I was stealing like shit.
That I had five different
Walmarts, press five felony
charges on me, in five different counties.
So I had five Walmart's looking for me.
And they were posting
my picture on Facebook.
They couldn't catch me.
I was stealing D, I would walk in
and I would put 500 Blu-ray DVDs
in a cart and push it out.
At $30 a pop it was like
20 grand and DVDs everyday
I'd push out of that store
and I'd get away with it.
And I was selling them the Arabs in Toledo
and making like a thousand
dollars a day, just boosting.
Living at my homeboy towns and you know
we've checked into this
family house place,
a program to help us get our kids back
and we started, we got clean
and we started doing programs
and she got on a drug court
and I was doing my probation.
We were doing everything.
We got a house, we got
our car back, we got jobs.
We started to get our
kids on the weekends.
And then she had one week
of drug court to do left,
and drug court's a hard
program to complete.
And she completed everything
and I was so proud
of her dude and I stayed
clean this whole time.
And she ended up dropping dirty
for last week of drug court.
So she fucked it up for
us. Fucked everything up.
So and despite of, you
know, my case worker was,
like dude, you're done, you
know, your kids are gone.
They're getting adopted
to your sister now.
If you want to go and try to
take and fight for the kids,
you're going to have to divorce Amanda.
You're going to have to do
all the courses back again.
And I was just, I was so, you know,
my kids were everything to me dude.
And my boys man, were everything to me.
So I just, it hurt so bad that
I'd have to leave my wife.
You know what I'm saying?
So I'm just like, I looked at her,
I'm like you know what Doon,
you did this shit, Doon.
I'm going to get a 20 sack of dope.
You know what I mean?
And I, boom, I hit it.
And she was like, well, we got this house
that we were fighting so hard for.
And now we got this house and
all our kids shit in there.
And then the kids are gone.
You know what I mean?
So like that, just that pain.
I just, I was trying to kill myself.
You know what I mean?
I was doing above and
beyond the amount of heroin
I should have did.
And I was just, boom, boom,
boom, doing, you know.
And we ended up getting raided
for selling dope out the house.
And I go to jail for nine days.
She goes to jail for nine days.
We both get out.
We come back to the house,
you know, I'm like, I'm done.
I'm not, I'm not touching
this shit no more, dude.
We lost our kids. We're
gonna lose this house.
This is for nothing. You
know what I'm saying?
What the fuck is the point?
We got nine days clean
and she's like, all right,
I have $11 in my pocket.
And I'm like, I'm going to go to the bar
and I'm going to have a beer.
So I go to the bar and she's
like, let me see that $10.
Dude, it was dollar beers.
Dude, I buy one beer?
And I turn around and she's gone.
And I'm like, what the
fuck? Where's she at?
I'm looking for her, I'm looking for her.
And I'm like, did you see
that blonde, cute girl, dude?
She's was out here.
Some guy who was saying
outside the bar was like,
Yeah, she just jumped in a car
with some black guy and took off.
I'm like, what the fuck, dude?
I know what she's doing,
she's going to get high.
So I go home and I'm like, you know,
sitting there waiting,
I'm calling her phone.
It goes straight to voicemail.
I'm like fuck, I don't know what to do.
So I fall asleep on the couch.
I get woke up at like four
o'clock in the morning.
There's like two cops
standing in my living room.
They said, Hey, do you
know Amanda Stiffler?
And I'm like, yeah, that's my wife.
And they were like, you
need to come with us.
I'm like for what?
And they're like, you
just need to come with us.
And I'm like, Oh fuck, dude.
I already knew what it was.
I'm like, I'm going to identify a body.
You know what I mean?
I already know she OD'ed,
you know what I mean?
And I'm like, I get in the back of the van
and I'm just like praying.
I'm like, please tell me,
is she okay? Is she okay?
And they're like, we can't
tell you anything, dude.
And I get to the hospital dude
and she's fucking hooked up head to toe,
fucking, she's got tubes down
her throat and everything.
And fucking, the cop tells me the story.
He's like, we got a phone call,
from an anonymous call, that
there was an OD at a house.
So we went to the house
and we knocked on the door
and the people not answer
the door and there was no OD.
They didn't know what the
hell we were talking about.
So we got back in the
cruiser and we were leaving
and something told me to
just drive down the alley.
So it's the middle of December.
There's three feet of snow on the ground.
It's snowing and raining.
And the cop finds her,
laying there in the alley
fucking soaking from
head to toe, unconscious.
She had been there for a half an hour,
blue, purple, she's dead.
And they took her back to the hood.
The guy that dumped her
and she ended up ODing in the house.
The guy dragged her,
threw her in the alley
and put a hoodie underneath her head.
And the hoodie is the only
thing that saved her life.
That from keeping it up out of the snow.
And she had melted through
three feet of snow.
They threw her in it and she was
all the way on the concrete.
So that's how long she
had been in the snow.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- They had hooked her up
to like all his machines
trying to bring her body temperature back.
And they hit her with
four shots of Narcan.
The first three they hit with,
you should come back off one immediately,
they hit her with another one.
They hit her with another one.
And this woman had three shots
of fucking Narcan that they hit her with.
And the doctor's like, she's done, dude.
She's just not coming back.
And the nurse was like, No,
I'm going to do one more shot.
I'm gonna do one more shot.
And the doctor's like, I'm
writing, I'm calling it.
You know, we're going to call it.
And that nurse pulled up
another shot of Narcan
and hit her with it.
And she barely came back just, uh,
just enough to start to breathe again.
And they resuscitate her,
got her to breathe and
everything like that.
She was out of it for about two days.
She finally comes to and
she's like, dude, babe,
I'm done, I'm done, I'm done. I'm sorry.
She's like, I didn't think,
I didn't think it was enough dude.
Like I went to the guy's house.
He put a little bit of
a powder on the table
and was like, this is my okay stuff.
And I got some better
stuff that, that, you know
and she was like, I got nine days clean.
This will be enough.
So she did a line of it.
And then she was like, you know what?
And she told me, she's like, I
knew what I was trying to do.
I was trying to OD. I
was trying to kill myself
because I was so, of the
situation of everything.
She's like, that didn't do anything to me.
Let me give some of the good stuff.
And she said, as soon as she did the line
of the mediocre stuff, she felt it, boom.
She knew it was strong.
So she knew the other stuff was, you know
and this is snorting it, she OD'ed.
She snorted it. She didn't even shoot it.
And she snorted a line and she said,
as soon as she snorted,
that's all she remembers.
And she woke up in the hospital.
And then after that,
she had stole a ring from
where she was working.
She used to clean like mansions and stuff.
She stole a ring like a
$25,000 ring from the mayor of
not Monroe, of Toledo, his dead wife.
So she was cleaning the mayor's mansion
and stole his dead wife's ring.
And you know, he took it to heart.
He did everything he could
to try to find this ring.
And she ended up, she came
home from work that day
and was like, you're not going to believe,
I found a wallet in the
park and I got 700 bucks.
I'm like, you found a wallet in the park.
Where is the wallet?
And she's like, Oh, I
threw it down in the park.
I'm like, let's go to
try to find the wallet.
Because I didn't believe
her. I knew what she did.
I'm like, you stole it. You
stole some gold from work.
She had done it you know, previously.
You know, I tell her, do not
steal nothing from work, dude.
You can't be doing that. We need that job.
You know what I mean?
It was something, you know,
it was bringing a little bit
of money in and then they
pressed charges on her.
And then they did like a
little sting operation,
where they came and they arrested her
and she went to jail.
And I sat in the house by
myself for about 60 days.
There she did about two months.
And then she finally
got out and I was clean.
She stayed clean for a little bit.
We started smoking crack
and she left with this black guy
and didn't come home for three weeks
and I called her and I'm like,
Hey, I've got a half
a gram of crack, dude,
if you come home, she was
there in fucking five minutes.
I'd been calling her phone
for three weeks straight.
She wouldn't answer. She wouldn't do shit.
I was like, Hey, I got a half gramy,
come home, I'll smoke it with you.
Five minutes later, she's outside.
Are you going to bring the half gram out?
I'm like, you honestly think
that I've got a half gram?
That I'm going to give you right now?
When you show up that fast.
I went nuts, dude. I ran out.
I tried killing the dude in the car.
They took off. They
took off again together.
So I went and I destroyed
everything in the house.
I broke every breakable
thing in the house.
I cut the couches up. I cut the bed up.
I took all her clothes.
I threw them in tub, I
dumped bleach all over them.
I broke every single dish. Every pitcher.
I cut the rugs up. I broke
everything other than the house.
You know what I mean?
I packed all my stuff I called her friend,
I was like, give me a ride,
give me a ride back to Michigan.
I'm going to go stay with my dad.
I went and I stayed with my dad.
I started working with my dad.
I was doing pretty good.
And then I ran into and old friend.
It was about six months I had clean,
seven months I had clean.
I ran into my old friend
and he was selling heroin.
And I had, you know, I
had thousands of dollars
I had been saving up. I
had like five grand on me.
I'm like fuck it, I'll do a pack.
I did a pack. Boom. I was
off to the races again.
I started, you know,
ended up back in jail.
Living in a tent after I had gotten,
I got out of jail with
my buddy, Carl Purdy.
He, he's dead now. He killed himself.
He fucking...
- In jail.
We were talking about killing ourself
when we had just got out of jail.
And we were just so fed
up with like everything.
Like the last five years of
my life had just been crazy.
You know what I mean?
Just absolute, just nuts man.
And like, just death and everyone
every, all my friends around me are dying
and you know, just like, I
was trying and to kill myself
but I never could, dude, I couldn't,
there wasn't enough dope in the world
that would kill me, dude.
I would do shots that people would be like
there's no way you're
coming back from this dude.
And I would do them and it
wouldn't even get me high.
Like I couldn't, I couldn't find death
when I was, when I was looking for it.
I was too afraid to hang myself,
too afraid to put a gun to my head.
But I would, I would put as much heroin
as I possibly could get in a rig
and shoot it up and try to die.
And it wouldn't work.
And I met this girl.
I ended up getting clean after all that.
I stayed in a tent for like three months.
We, me and Carl, we got clean together
and I met my, my latest baby mama Sarah.
I had moved to Toledo, that's
when we had got them pills.
And we had, went to the,
we ended up in Florida with my mom.
We were clean the whole
summer, everything was cool.
And we just couldn't take
it no more, staying out.
We started sleeping in a tent
because the house was so nasty.
We couldn't take it. So me
and Sarah was in a tent.
There was fire ants everywhere.
And they were biting us and shit.
And we were like, dude, we
can't take this anymore.
- She started her period.
- She started her period, dude.
And she, we were just
like, she was just over it.
- He was like mom, we're leaving.
- She called her parents
and was like, mom,
send me a couple of hundred bucks.
We're going to, we're
going to come to Vegas.
Her parents own nine car
washes in Grants Pass,
Oregon, a construction company
and a couple of other businesses.
They were entrepreneurs.
- Yeah, they're rich.
- Rich, rich multi-millionaires.
And I didn't know this.
I didn't know that she
came from that much money.
So we pull up to this
gated community in Vegas.
Mansions, just mansions everywhere.
And I'm like, are you kidding me, Sarah?
She's like, yeah, this
is where my parents live.
I'm like, and we've been
struggling this long, dude.
And your parents live in a
fucking three story, man.
We come in, everything's white.
You know, they got
Escalades in the driveway.
I'm like, are you kidding me, dude?
Like, she's like, yeah babe,
I said, I come from money.
I'm like, I didn't think you
came from this much money dude.
So I, you know, I meet her
her parents and everything
and they're like, well,
this is what we plan to do.
- They hate him.
- They hated me from the get go, you know?
And as soon as they see
me, they're like, well,
that's not what we
expected you to look like.
And I'm like, what did they mean by that?
Like I thought maybe they thought me,
expected me to look worse or I don't know.
I don't know, I didn't, I don't know.
I didn't know how to take it.
But you know, we're sitting there
I tell their parents my whole life story
and they start crying.
You know what I mean?
And they're like, well, we
already made a decision.
Shane, you're getting on a plane,
you're going back to Michigan,
Sarah, you're going to Oregon,
and you move in with your sister.
I started balling.
And I'm like, if I go back
to Detroit, I'm dying.
I'm dead. You know what I mean?
And she's like, dad, you can't
send him back to Detroit.
He's going to die. You know what I mean?
And I was to the point to
like, if they would've put me
on a plane, I would've,
you know what I mean?
It would've, it was, I
was, I was so fed up.
I was just like so done with
struggling and just like
I was ready just for, to
change everything in my life.
So I'm like, look dude, please dude,
this is what, you got to
just loan us some money.
I'm like give us $5,000, dude.
Let us go to Oregon,
let us get an apartment.
We'll both get jobs
and we'll pay you back.
And he's like, all right, we'll do that.
So he writes us a check for five grand.
Me and Sarah go to, go to Oregon.
We get an apartment, I
get a construction job.
She gets a job working at the gas station.
And we do it, we pay her parents back.
We're there for about six months.
And we're doing really good,
we've got money in the bank.
We're living in a little shitty apartment
But we're together. You
know what I'm saying?
We're clean.
Boom. She pops up, she's pregnant.
She tells her parents that,
Hey, we're pregnant and
her parents just lose it.
They're like, what the fuck?
Get an abortion now. You're dumb.
It's the stupidest
decision you've ever done.
Like, no, you cannot have this baby.
You're not financially
stable, blah, blah, blah.
You know what I mean?
And we're like, dude, who cares?
You know what I'm saying?
We're fighting, we're,
the baby is going to be,
we're going to be fine, dude.
You know what I mean?
And like, and they come
to accept it, you know?
And we end up, you know,
we had our son, Noah.
- [Kelly] Then you started snorting coke.
- [Shane] And I got my ID and
the day I got my ID, dude,
I went out to the bar.
And I had been, I'd been clean
for shit, almost a year now.
And I just wanted to snort
a line of coke so bad.
And I found, I was just like,
I met this little Mexican
kid sitting there.
I started going out and
he's selling cocaine.
And then him and Alex start
selling cocaine together.
And they were up to like
selling an ounce a week
or whatever.
And I've been selling drugs
since I was 15 years old.
You know what I mean?
They're making a little bit of money.
Alex bought a new car,
Don bought a new car.
I see him. I don't have
a car at this point.
Sarah's driving me around everywhere.
I'm like, I want a car dude.
Me and Sarah are living
paycheck to paycheck, dude.
I want some of this money.
So I got to Dom one night,
I go into the bar and I'm like,
Hey bro, you need to talk to me.
He's like, I already knew what it was.
I already knew he was messing with heroin.
I could see the redness in his face.
And he like, he was on
the verge of tears, dude.
And we weren't even really,
we had known each other.
We weren't like kicking
it, but we were friends.
You know what I mean?
I'm like, you need to come to the car.
And all I wanted was a
line of Coke, to be honest.
And I'm like, you need to come to the car,
we went out to his car and
I just grill him, dude.
He didn't say a word.
I'm like, dude, you're addicted to heroin.
You're selling this cocaine.
And I just laid it all on him.
Dude, he starts crying.
And he's like, how the
fuck did you knew that?
Dude, how did you just know everything
that I was going through in life
without me even telling you, dude.
I'm like, I can see it in your eyes, dude.
I can, I've lived it.
You know what I mean?
And he's like I, because at that point
he had lost everything and he was trying
to sell cocaine to get it all back.
And I'm like, look dude, you and Alex
are out here selling
cocaine, you guys are dumb,
and you're doing it all wrong.
You know what I mean?
You're, how much are you selling a week?
And he's like, me and Alex are
doing like an ounce a week.
I'm like, how about this dude?
How about you front me some cocaine, dude.
And I'm going to show you
how to really sell cocaine.
I'm going to tell you,
show you how to sell drugs.
And he's like, all right.
I'm like, look, I'm
going to be the top dog.
I just basically jumped
in and strong armed him
and took over his whole operation.
I'm like, I'm going to be
the brains of the outfit.
And I'm going to tell you what to do,
where to do it, how to do it.
And you be the main guy.
You're the, you're the main guy.
You know what I mean?
So all eyes are on you.
So I was calling all the shots
and he's just the front man.
He had the Chrysler 300 at that time,
all white Chrysler 300 with white rims.
And we'd all dress up in white button ups
and a bunch of gold.
So we just looked like
cocaine dealers, you know?
And we went from him, starting off at,
he was doing about an ounce a week.
By the time we were up and running
and we were really flowing.
We got up to eight pounds.
We had at one time, well, we were,
we worked our way up to four ki's.
- It was a lot.
- And we do good for the
fuck, about a year running.
I'm making 5 to $10,000
a day, in real money.
So I'm throwing wads of money at my mom.
And she's like, I got so much money.
I don't know what to do with it.
I got four cars in the
driveway, a motorcycle,
a dirt bike, we're going to the strip club
and just throwing thousands on the,
you know living it up.
And you know, me and my mom, just fuck,
we're snorting lines all night.
And then I couldn't come down.
I'd be up for fucking, I literally,
I have no septum in my nose,
deviated septum from
snorting so much coke.
And my nose would just
bleed and bleed and hurt.
I'd wake up and do a gram line.
It wouldn't even get me high.
I do an eight ball before it was noon.
You know what I mean?
And I'm like, fuck dude,
this shit ain't get me high.
And then, so I started shooting it.
I'm like, start banging coke.
And then I'm so high off the coke.
I'm like fuck, I need to come down.
So I fucking meet this
chick, that could get black.
I never even knew fucking, I
didn't even look for heroin.
For the three years that
I was selling cocaine
in Grants Pass, I didn't even look for it.
But the come down was getting so bad
from the cocaine addiction that I had.
I had, I had to do something.
So I start doing heroin,
and then my cocaine cells
start getting slower and getting slower
and getting slower and getting slower.
So where I'm totally
focused I'm just doing black
and doing black.
And in the beginning, yeah,
I'd pull up to my dope man's
house and throw off five racks.
And you know, buy an ounce of heroin.
And then sit in my room.
Then my mom would come into my room dude,
and just be like, dude, move.
I would sit on my bed, dude.
- His feet would be so
swollen up from just sitting.
- I would sit on the bed dude
and just get high and get high.
Sarah had left with my
son and she had moved out.
- His mattress had a
permanent indent where he sat.
- Dude, I'd have my
homies come over, dude.
And I wouldn't even sleep.
I would sleep sitting in this spot.
I probably sat in this
spot for 30 days straight
and didn't leave my room.
The only time I'd leave, just to get food
and to go to the bathroom dude.
And then when I would go to the bathroom
I would fucking fall asleep on the toilet
and be knocked out.
- I yelled his name at
least 50,000 times a day.
- Burning holes all over.
- Cigarette burns everywhere.
- Just getting Superman high.
- It was bad, so bad.
- I was doing about an eight ball a day.
And you know, and just, I was
still selling a little bit
of coke and I was just got,
you know this, I had just went
and got this brand new nine
and somebody called me for a eight ball
and I, and I'm like, yeah, I'll serve him.
You know what I'm saying?
It was like four o'clock in
the morning I walk outside
and I'm like, they're
like, Hey, is there coke?
They've got five people in the car.
They're like, Hey, is the coke good?
I'm like, yeah, the coke's fire man.
And he's like, all right,
cool, let me check it out.
So I go to check them
out and yo, I'm like,
bro, don't do nothing dumb,
dude or I will shoot you.
You know what I'm saying?
And they're like, go, go, go.
And I'm fuck and I just,
I didn't think about it.
Boom, I pull my gun
and bah, bah, bah, bah.
I shot you know fucking,
put five or six rounds
in the back of the truck.
Popped the tire, popped the gas tank,
blew out the back window.
Thank God I didn't hit nobody, you know.
Thank God I didn't hit nobody.
And they, they all jump off the truck
and they all take off running.
The cops come, I'm hiding in the house.
Cops come, look at the truck.
Truck's fucking riddled
full of bullet holes.
So they tow the truck.
So they lost their truck.
But then I got a reputation.
You know what I'm saying?
In that town, for don't
fuck with that guy.
You know what I mean?
He will fucking shoot you.
And I just, I was, I at that
point I was just crazy, dude.
I didn't give a fuck.
I was just, I had lost,
my second family that, I
had lost my first family.
I went to Oregon to do it all
better, to do it all good.
And it's still, still just fucked up.
You know what I mean?
I just, I couldn't hold it
together, but it was the drugs.
You know what I'm saying?
It was the fast life.
It was the money. It was the girls.
And then that chick that
I had met the first night
that I had went out, Rachel,
she was just obsessed with
me from the day we had met.
And she just would come
over and come over.
And we, me and her were
having a little affair,
you know behind Sarah's back.
- Now he's got a baby with her.
- I got her pregnant,
you know what I'm saying?
So we kept it a secret but everybody knew,
everybody knew, but they
were so terrified of me
that they wouldn't say.
Nobody would, Sarah's best friends knew
about me and Rachel's affair,
but they wouldn't tell Sarah.
Because I literally threatened their life.
You know, I would go
up to them and I'd say
if you ruin my life and you tell Sarah
about what's going on,
I will fucking kill you.
And I'd pull the gun out
and I'd set it on the table.
And I'd be like, you ruin
mine, I will ruin yours.
You know? And that's where I was.
Because I didn't, I love Sarah so much,
I did not want to lose her.
But I had this fucking horrible secret
the whole time that I was,
and that's why I started getting high.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I was dealing with this.
And one day somebody called
her that didn't know me.
She had went to high school with him,
but he had found out and was like,
that's my friend from
school and he calls her.
And me and Sarah were fighting a lot.
And you know what I mean?
And just, she was never happy.
She was never satisfied.
My ma had broke up with
her boyfriend in Florida.
So I said, you know what?
I flew, I flew her out and
you can come stay with me.
I had an extra bedroom in the house.
I'm like, ma, you come and stay with me.
So my ma, then she moved in with us.
Her and Sarah started
butting heads immediately.
And you know, it just,
they didn't get along.
So Sarah moved out
and then I ended up
getting Rachel pregnant.
Now me and Rachel got a kid.
And Sarah won't answer my phone calls
she won't do nothing.
- She won't even let you see Noah.
- She won't let me see Noah.
- Me neither.
- Once I got out of jail, this last time
me and Rachel got into it.
She told me to go kill her, kill myself.
Because all I do is ruin
everybody's life and shit.
And she moved to Portland,
blacked me on everything.
So now Rachel, that was
totally obsessed with me
that wanted to marry me, now she hates me.
You know, now Sarah hates me.
Now, you know what I mean?
My sister won't let me
see none of my kids.
So now I'm like fuck, you win.
I ended up, my lease is
done on my apartment.
My ex tells my landlord about everything.
About the drugs, about the
raid, about everything.
So my landlord is like, I'm
not signing another year lease.
Dude, you're done, you know.
So we're on the street, we're kicked out.
We're living out of my car,
we're staying at the hotels
and shit.
And I end up, she meets this guy.
- Sugar Daddy.
- Sugar Daddy and we conned
him into giving us $5,000.
- He gave us a lot of money.
- Probably a $100,000 in the last year.
Yeah. We've got him out
of about a hundred grand.
- He bought us a lot.
- He gave us a lot, yeah.
I ended up buying a new job.
I did, I started, I
started just doing weed
and I started shipping
weed back to Detroit
and I had a really good connect.
So they'd mail me like 10,000.
I'd go pick up five or six pounds,
package them up and ship them back East,
I'd make 5 or 6,000
like a week doing that.
So it was some money.
You know what I mean?
It was just a little,
it was enough to for,
I was still helping Sarah pay her rent
and give my kid whatever he wanted
and taking her shopping
and staying in hotels and everything.
And then, you know the weed thing
just started to slow down a little bit.
Cause there was, it was so dry.
There was no weed available.
You know what I'm saying?
- That's when you said
you wanted to go to Vegas.
- That's when I was just like...
- That's how we ended up here.
- Let's just go to Vegas, dude.
And I had went to jail
and I was on a felony
paper and my home girl,
she was the one that was in
the house that went to jail.
That when I got raided, I
had a chick that was over,
and she had warrants. She
ended up going to jail.
And then yeah, anyway, she,
she got, she was in Vegas
cause she was running
on a delivery charge.
I got a delivery of cocaine out of Oregon.
She's like, come to Vegas dude.
- Because we both got warrants.
We can't go, I can't go back to Michigan.
He can't go back to Oregon.
- I can't go back to Michigan
I can't go back to Ohio.
I can't go back to Oregon.
I can't go back to Tennessee.
Yeah. We're like, we're just, you know,
I got four felony rulings
in four different states.
- If I go back to Michigan
I'm going to prison,
if he goes back to Oregon,
he's going back to prison.
- I'm going to prison in
Oregon, Michigan, Ohio
and some county time in Tennessee.
- And I'm not going back because
I'm not doing five years.
- [Mark] So what do you guys
see for your future from here?
You get arrested or you're just down here?
- We're just here and we're
like taking it on day by day
- And I'm to the point
to where I'm just like,
you know what I'm going
to go back to Oregon
and I'm just going to chop
it up and do my 22 months.
- I don't want him to go back.
Because I don't want to be here alone.
- I just, I miss my son, some goddam bad.
I want, I want to be
in my son's life, dude.
That's, that kills me every day.
You know what I mean?
And I know if I go back to Oregon,
and I get a job and I get an
apartment and I'm doing good
and I stay sober, Sarah's
gonna let me see my son.
You know what I mean?
- And if I...
- You're going to go to
prison for five years
- I know I'm going to do 22 months.
That's if I go back and I talk to my PO,
and say, Hey, look,
this is what's going on.
This is what you know,
this is what had happened.
We had dipped out, went to Vegas.
We come to, well, we left Vegas
cause it was horrible, dude.
I absolutely hated it there. It was hot.
We had nowhere to go
We were sleeping in the
car all day, you know?
And we're just struggling,
struggling to put $2
in a gas tank to even
just, you know what I mean?
We're trying to hustle
up money on the strip
and it's just not working for us.
Dude, so we're like,
you know, we call Paul,
the guy that gives us, you know,
that sends us money and stuff.
- We led him on for so many...
- We led him on for a
while, and now he's done.
He's burned, you know, he's done.
It ain't happening no more.
We get a couple of hundred from him
we throw it in the gas tank, we come here,
we're staying out in Santa Monica
we're just sleeping in the car.
- The car gets towed.
- You know, we park in
the wrong parking spot.
Cops tow the car. So now we're homeless
and we ain't got nowhere to go.
We got like $100.
- We're living in a tent in skid row.
You know? Fuck.
So, yeah.
- That's that story.
- Yeah, that's that dude.
- We're hoping that, I don't
know, I don't know what.
- I mean, we've got our GR, dude.
Well we get $400 every
month, if we get food stamps.
I mean like, it's like
right now, I'm like in limbo
like I always have been,
I can sit and I can,
it's like to be honest,
it's like when I was selling
and when I was doing all this
with great money comes
great responsibilities.
So my phone would never stop ringing.
I would always have
somewhere to go and somewhere
to do when something, something
stressed me out, you know?
So I'd constantly be stressed
out and I would, you know
I'd love that lifestyle.
But at the same time,
I hated that lifestyle.
You know what I'm saying?
The money was just a side
product of that lifestyle
that just comes with it.
You know what I'm saying?
She's addicted to this type of lifestyle.
She loves the streets.
She loves the fast pace, the running.
Me, I don't like the dirtiness of it.
I don't like the, for me, it's hard to
you know what I'm saying?
I like to have a woman.
You know what I'm saying?
I like to have a girl next to me.
So it's for me.
I haven't talked to a girl
since I left the Oregon.
You know what I'm saying?
So I got all these girls back in Oregon
calling me every day, come
home, come home, come home.
We miss you.
And I'm stuck in fucking LA.
And I can't meet a girl to save my life
because what I'm going to say.
Oh yeah, we live in a tent
in skid row with my mom
You know?
Yeah. Running from the fucking law
from four different fucking States.
Living in a tent with
my ma, shooting dope.
You know what I mean?
Like, Oh yeah, I want to
come over and hang out.
Can I stay the night?
You know what I mean?
Like, it don't look good.
Unless I'm going to meet
some other scallywag,
you know, girl from the streets here,
that's living in a tent too.
That's dirtier than I am.
You know what I'm saying?
Which I've never, would never do.
You know what I mean?
I can't stoop that low,
unless she's absolutely
drop dead gorgeous.
And she just got here last week.
You know what I'm saying?
I might. You know what I'm saying?
Fuck dude. But yeah,
dude, it's been a journey.
I think what is in my future is,
I'm just going to have to go
back to Oregon and chop it up.
Because the Oregon is home to me, man.
Oregon has felt like no other
place I ever felt in my life.
And I was never accepted in Michigan dude.
Everywhere I went, I had
this last name Stiffler.
So, you know, I, all of her
brothers and all my family,
they all have this,
you know, this who they are,
you know what I'm saying?
Oh, they're Stifflers, you
know, they'll fuck you over.
They'll do this. They're shady.
You know what I mean?
So I grew up as a shady Stiffer,
you know what I'm saying?
Even though I wasn't that guy,
I got labeled as that guy.
Because of who my fucking family was.
So I never fit in everywhere I went.
Oh, he's a Stiffler you
know what I'm saying?
So immediately I'm like,
I'm the outcast guy.
Don't trust him. You know what I'm saying?
- That's how it was for me.
- And then people would get to know me
and they'd be like Stiffler
he's, you know, Shane,
he's a good dude. You
know what I'm saying?
Like, he's got morals.
If he says he's gonna do
something, he's going to do it.
You know what I mean?
So, I mean, I have that after
I'd meet somebody for awhile
or hang out with them, but then I just,
I could never, I never had
my own car in Michigan.
I never had a driver's
license in Michigan.
I never had my own apartment in Michigan.
It wasn't until I went to
Ohio right over the line.
Boom. I had everything.
You know what I mean?
As soon as I got out of Michigan, boom,
it all came to me like it was nothing.
- Right.
- I moved to Oregon, had everything.
You know what I mean?
Like I said, I've had five
fortunes and squandered them,
You know.
Beautiful homes and cars
in the driveway and money.
I mean, I had so much
money in my safe in Oregon,
I couldn't close my safe,
you know, all hundreds,
all hundreds. I'm trying
to close the safe with ma.
Look at this dude.
Can't even close the safe
there's too much money in it.
You know. But then, fuck now look.
Now we're paying, I got a dollar,
I got $1 in my pocket.
- I got two.
- She's got two, I got one.
Oh, we're doing something today.
No, fuck. Yeah.
- [Mark] All right you guys.
That was a hell of a story.
- Wasn't it?
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with,
whatever you end up doing.
- I know.
- We're going to need it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Definitely. Yep, I need a ciggie break.